a lot of tv spot trailer footage is just
released so i'm going to break it down
for you guys right now the first trailer
begins with new dialogue from peter
where he says truth is i accidentally
brought those dangerous people here the
world if you're watching wish me luck
friendly neighborhood spiderman could
really use something so we have a new
shot here of overlooking the city and
then the next shot we actually have
peter parker being broadcasted to the
daily bugle throughout the city now we
can see here if we zoom in here it says
peter parker calls into the daily bugle
and obviously spider-man here is
unmasked so this confirms which we knew
previously that the spell has gone wrong
and it didn't work at all so people
still know who peter parker is as you
can see he's not trying to hide his
identity and this is definitely in the
later half of the film peter parker's
injured here and he's referring to the
villains saying i brought those
dangerous people here by accident which
we know the villains come in after the
spell has failed moving on we have
spider-man falling throughout the sky
while holding the cube this is during
the um doctor strange versus spider-man
fight where doctor strange is chasing
him to try and get the cube off him
which we actually see more shots of here
with doctor strangers gliding throughout
the sky with his cape following from
behind and then this trailer ends off
with peter parker broadcast into his
phone the next trailer starts off with
new dialogue from doctor strange saying
if that spell gets loose they're all
coming here with this new dialogue scene
we have a new shot of peter parker
holding the cue ball listening to doctor
strange and dr strange is obviously
referring to the villains getting loose
because as we know the villains are
trapped inside of this cube inside of
this prison at the moment presumably
peter parker has been influenced to try
to help the villains escape if not
they'll be transported back to the world
and presumably killed the next thing we
have is a new dialogue sequence of
doctor strange saying don't do this and
peter's saying i have to try so just as
i said before peter parker is trying to
help the villains escape because he
doesn't want them to be transported back
to the world because he thinks they will
die killing is against spider-man's
morals he doesn't want to kill you wants
to try save as many lives as he can and
but in this scenario doctor strange is
actually right peter parker doesn't know
what he's getting himself into and as we
know he actually does help the villains
escape and then they just wreck mayhem
while we are in the topic of villains we
have a new shot of the green goblin here
but his mask is actually seen broken
here we do know later in the movie he
actually um has this new look which has
no mask and you know this is just
confirmed here his mask is scene broken
in the background you can actually see
him running away it looks pretty goofy
not gonna lie but you know we haven't
seen the full sequence to full shot but
um yeah i'm curious how does this mask
get broken i imagine during a fight with
spider-man or something like that
possibly an explosion goes off or just
general combat with spider-man but who
knows i guess we'll just have to wait
and see anyway moving on we have a
couple new shots here we have a new shot
of spider-man during the spider-man vs
doctor strange fight it's just him on
top of a floating rock looking around
probably doctor strangers casting some
spells or some crazy doctor strange
stuff is going on because as we can see
in the background there's you know
buildings connected to rocks and
everything's just floating around so
peter's probably quite confused and
doctor strange is probably using all the
cards he has to try to get this creep
off peter moving on we have doctor
strange casting and spell we can see the
runes being placed everywhere in the sky
now i believe this scene here is
actually strange is actually recasting
the spell that the star would film which
failed the spell being everyone
forgetting the identity of spider-man
but who knows let me know what you guys
think of this in the comment section
below anyway with that out of the way
that pretty much wraps up this video so
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching guys